The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, so
up until now, we've
been talking about the
shortest path in graphs.
And we've been talking
about these game problems
where you came up with a way to
represent the state of a game
as noting graphs.
And then we drew edges between
those vertices that represented
states, to represent moves
that you can do in a game.
It turns out you can solve
a lot of problems this way.
And you can do it without
thinking of a graph at all.
So we usually think of a
graph, build the graph,
then run dynamic programming.
You can do better without
building the graph.
And the good part about that
is that your code is smaller,
and it runs faster.
The bad part about that is
it's harder to understand.
The dynamic programming
code looks like black magic.
And, when we're going to
give you dynamic programming
problems on the final,
you can't say, oh,
we're going to build something
and run [? dystring ?].
And get partial credit.
You actually have to
understand the magic,
and write the formulas,
and hopefully get
something that works.
So, we're going to spend all
the time that we have left
in the semester, I
think, building up
your intuition for how to
build dynamic programming.
So, from lecture,
dynamic programming
is just a catchy name for
for optimization problems.
So, problems where
you're trying to compute
the minimum or the
maximum of something.
So let's start with a problem.
And then, see how all
the concepts in lecture
relate to that.
So this problem is
called Crazy Eights.
And we start out with a deck
of cards, randomly shuffled.
And then some of the
cards are pulled out.
Did everyone see playing cards?
Poker cards?
Does everyone know what they
are or do I have to define them?
Does anyone need me
to define poker cards?
Let's put it that way.
OK.
Cool.
So, suppose we have
a bunch of these.
AUDIENCE: I don't know
what Crazy Eights is.
PROFESSOR: We'll get to that.
AUDIENCE: OK.
It's an 8.
AUDIENCE: I know
what an 8 is, but I
don't know how the game works.
PROFESSOR: OK.
We'll get to it.
So, let's see.
4 of spades.
OK, so this is a
bunch of cards that
were pulled out of the deck.
And we want the longest
crazy subsequence.
And the crazy subsequence
is a subsequence
where two cards are
like each other.
The way we define like
is that either they
have the same number.
Or they have the same suit.
Or one of them is an 8.
So an 8 is like anything else.
OK.
So 4 and 8.
Are they like each other?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: 8 and 5.
Are they like each other?
AUDIENCE: Yep.
PROFESSOR: OK.
this 5, 5 of hearts
and 9 of diamonds.
Are they like each other?
No.
5 of hearts and 7 of hearts.
Are they like each other?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: 5 of spades and 7
of hearts, like each other?
No.
OK.
So we have some cards
that are like each other.
We want the longest
possible subsequence.
AUDIENCE: What about 5 and 5?
Those are like each other.
PROFESSOR: They're
like each other, yep.
They are more cards that are
like each other than the ones
I drew here.
For example, this guy
is like everything else.
Oh, we already drew that one.
OK.
So how do we model this
problem using graphs?
So, stuff that we knew
before the last lecture.
AUDIENCE: Those
could all be nodes.
PROFESSOR: OK.
All the cards are nodes.
That's good.
And, I want the longest
path between what and what?
AUDIENCE: One node to another?
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: The longest
path in the graph.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
The longest path in the graph.
One trick to reduce
it to a known problem
is to add the fake source.
So this is a fake source.
And it's going to
connect to everything.
And this way, I want the longest
path, starting from the source.
AUDIENCE: And the other source?
PROFESSOR: Nope.
The longest path, starting from
the source, ending anywhere
in the graph.
AUDIENCE: Such that it doesn't
go touch another card again?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So, if I want a
longer subsequence,
that's a good question.
How would the edges look?
AUDIENCE: Directed.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
Directed.
And which direction?
AUDIENCE: Arbitrary [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So, if I choose
this one and this one,
can I go back afterwards?
AUDIENCE: You just
can't go back to the 4.
PROFESSOR: So, in the
longest common subsequence,
all the cards have to
be in increasing order.
So I can say I'm going to
choose this one, this one,
and this one.
And they have to
match in this order.
So I can only go forward.
So I can't reorder the cards.
My answer has to be, say, 4
of diamonds, 8 of diamonds.
And then, what else
would match that?
9 of diamonds.
AUDIENCE: You can put the
8 anywhere, though, right?
PROFESSOR: No.
I can't move them.
So the cards have to be
in the initial order.
I don't have to
choose all the cards,
but the cards that I
choose have to respect
the initial ordering.
AUDIENCE: So everything
points right.
PROFESSOR: Everything
Forward.
Yep.
And, I need one more
edge from here to here.
AUDIENCE: Oh, so you're
saying in the game
you get an initial order.
And you can't reorder it.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
But otherwise I can, if
I have all the cards,
I'm just going to order them.
AUDIENCE: Well, that's
the point right?
I was picturing more like
you get a set of cards
and you try to figure out--
PROFESSOR: No.
So, that's a different game.
That might be harder to solve,
so let's stick with this.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why is 8
in there, with 7?
PROFESSOR: 8 is
similar to anything.
Just for the heck of it.
These are the rules.
OK, so we have a
graph and we want
to compute the longest path.
We do not have an algorithm
We only have algorithms
to compute shortest paths.
So how do I deal with that?
We had that in problem set six.
AUDIENCE: Make all
weights negative
because there's no
cycle [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
We know it's negative.
And, I guess these
ones don't matter.
But all these are going
to be, instead of being 1,
they're all going to be -1.
Very good.
And there are no
cycles in this graph,
so we know that the answer
will be well defined.
OK.
Everyone with me so far?
Happy nods?
Yes.
So, what algorithm do I know
that solves this problem?
AUDIENCE: Bellman-Ford.
PROFESSOR: Bellman-Ford.
Good.
What is the running
time of Bellman-Ford?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Cool.
Suppose I have N cards.
How many vertices do I have?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Plus the source.
It's ordering.
So you're right.
How many edges do I have?
Worst case.
AUDIENCE: N squared.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] you mean,
like, the directed [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: No, I
mean Bellman-Ford.
Then, we're going to
go to that algorithm
and get the better running time.
AUDIENCE: Cause isn't
Bellman-Ford e times e?
PROFESSOR: Oh.
What?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's what
I-- Did someone say, v plus e?
Or did I write v plus e?
Yep.
You did.
Thank you.
So it's v times e.
So the total running time is.
aUDIENCE: N squared.
aUDIENCE: N cubed.
AUDIENCE: Or, n cubed.
Yeah, it's multiplying
[INAUDIBLE], too.
PROFESSOR: You guys
are mean today.
OK, so n cubed
applying Bellman-Ford.
There is a better way of
solving this problem, right?
The Directed Acyclic
Graph Bellman-Ford.
So let's look at the Directed
Acyclic Graph, not the one
to be generated by this because
that might be a bit messy.
And let's try to
compute shortest path.
s, a, b, c.
OK, so let's see
how we'd compute
the shortest path in this graph.
It's Acyclic, right?
All the the edges are
pointing downwards.
So let's try to
compute them directly.
I'm not going to write
pseudocode first.
I'm going to write
the formulas, and that
will get the intuition for it.
Then, maybe right psuedocode.
So what is the distance
from the source to itself?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Good.
The first ones are easy, so
I'm going to do them myself.
sa is 1.
sb is 2.
sc is 3.
And, of course, you guys
get to do the hard ones.
So the distance
from s to d is what?
How would I compute it?
AUDIENCE: There's two paths
to get to [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
So, I would want the shortest
path from those, right?
OK.
So it's 4.
And the formula for it is the
minimum of two paths, right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] S
to b, and then b to b.
PROFESSOR: So, one path is--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
and s [? and b ?].
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Wait.
sa.
So, first there's
a path from s to a.
And the edge a to d.
And then, there's
a path from s to b.
And the 8 from b to d, right?
And I already know the
values for sa and sb,
so this is well defined.
We can compute it right away.
No recursion.
No metrics.
I mean, there's recursion, but
there's no infinite recursion.
Does this make sense?
So, in order to get to d, there
are two edges pointing into d.
One of them coming from a.
One of them coming from b.
So I can either get to
a and take this edge.
Or get to b and take this edge.
This is what the
formulas are saying.
How about se?s
What's the formula?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
What are they?
AUDIENCE: s3.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, sa, sb, sc.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Aed's.
PROFESSOR: And the number?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] 3?
I think.
e to e.
PROFESSOR: OK.
f.
Someone that hasn't
spoken today.
So that I can see
that everyone gets it.
Please.
AUDIENCE: dsb--
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: --plus wef.
AUDIENCE: And dsc plus wcf.
PROFESSOR: Awesome.
And that is--
PROFESSOR: 4.
PROFESSOR: I'll take
your word for it.
OK, so now the last one.
Distance from std.
AUDIENCE: 5.
Wait.
No.
PROFESSOR: So, let's
write a formula.
AUDIENCE: Oh, g, not a.
AUDIENCE: That's 5.
AUDIENCE: 5.
PROFESSOR: OK, so
let's write a formula
to make sure that you
guys are computing it
in the fastest
possible way for me.
So--
sd plus sd to g.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Does anyone else?
Is this the only path?
AUDIENCE: No.
There's more.
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: Plus e as to f.
PROFESSOR: Plus e as f.
AUDIENCE: And n.
AUDIENCE: c to f.
I mean, c to g.
Or, No. no.
s to c.
PROFESSOR: OK.
See, there's a trick.
OK.
Cool.
And then, what are the weights?
AUDIENCE: w e to g.
PROFESSOR: e to g.
Very good.
AUDIENCE: fg.
PROFESSOR: fg.
AUDIENCE: cg.
PROFESSOR: cg.
AUDIENCE: Why are
you adding in c?
AUDIENCE: Because
there's the extra c.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I didn't see that.
PROFESSOR: So, the point of this
guy's, is that if you do bfs,
you'll get tricked.
Because bfs would put g on
the same level as these.
And might compute
the value for g
before it has the
values for these.
OK, so what order do I need
to compute these numbers in,
for this to work?
AUDIENCE: That way
you computed them?
PROFESSOR: So, that is a, that
is a, something of the graph.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Oh, topological.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Stole your answer.
Topological sort.
So, any of the
topological sorts works.
The one we used this
time is sabcdefg.
Why am I using a
topological sort?
AUDIENCE: Because
there's dependency.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
So, this depends on
this and this, right?
As c depends on sa, as b as c.
So basically, every edge
here indicates a dependency.
In order to compute the shortest
distance from the source
to here, I need to
know the shortest
distance from the
source to these two.
And then I can
look at the edges.
So, the nice thing
about a topological sort
is, after I write the
vertices this way,
all the edges point forward.
Right? s to a. s to b.
s to c.
a to d.
a to e.
b to d.
b to e.
b to f.
I can keep going.
But the point is, there's no
such thing as a backward edge.
So if I compute the numbers in
this order, when I get to se,
I know that I computed the
distance from s to abcd.
And if I have any
edge coming into e,
I know that I've already
computed the shortest distance
to the node that
it is coming from.
yes?
Did I lose you guys?
Was this too--
AUDIENCE: So
basically, like, at a,
you relaxed all the
edges going out of it.
PROFESSOR: You can
look at it that way.
But what we're doing here
is I'm looking at a node
and I'm relaxing all the
edges coming into a node.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: So this
matches this order.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: What you said
doesn't match this order.
But it's exactly the same thing.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
PROFESSOR: It'll give
you the same result.
AUDIENCE: You'd get the first
value at g when you reach c.
But, like, end up
with the same answer.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
AUDIENCE: We're still going
backwards then, instead of--
PROFESSOR: As long as
you're processing the nodes
in the topological sort
order, all the algorithms
will work because
you're just computing
these terms in a
different order.
But as long as the
dependencies are satisfied,
you're still going to
get the right thing.
OK, so what's the
running time of this?
How many people know
the running time
without having to write
pseudocode for this?
I know the answer beforehand,
so I cheated, obviously.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Is it a?
[INAUDIBLE] edges.
PROFESSOR: Almost.
Very close.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: So, it's
the topological.
So, running time
plus the running time
for evaluating this.
The running time for evaluating
this is v plus e because you
have every h shows up
exactly once in here.
So you have e terms.
And you have v vertices, even
if you don't have any edge,
you have to initialize
the verdicts.
So that's why it's v plus e.
AUDIENCE: It's also
topological sort.
PROFESSOR: So, this is the
order in which we process this.
So everything is v plus e.
If we use this algorithm
to solve this problem,
what will the running time be?
AUDIENCE: n.
AUDIENCE: n squared.
AUDIENCE: It's an no.
PROFESSOR: So, it's v
prime plus u prime, which
is n squared plus [INAUDIBLE]
squared, which is n squared.
So, by observing that
this graph is acyclic,
we have a better running
time than Bellman-Ford.
Even though we used
exactly the same intuition
that we used up until now.
Model the problem as a graph.
Figure out what the edges are.
Run a shortest path algorithm.
We have a better
shortest path algorithm,
which works for
Directed Acyclic Graphs,
so we get a better running time.
OK, questions for
what we did so far?
AUDIENCE: It's [INAUDIBLE]
on this graph here,
then you would do
the same thing.
Take each node and then
relax the incoming edges.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So what is the
topological sort of this?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It's exactly
the cards in the order
that they're on
the board, right?
So, in dynamic programming,
the topological sort order
is obvious.
So the hard part is
representing the state
and figuring out what
the dependencies are.
So what the edges are.
And after that, the
topological sort usually comes,
it's fairly straightforward.
OK, so what we can do now,
we have a few directions
in which we can go.
We can write the
pseudocode for this.
I mean, it's
basically, it's just,
we're going to write abstract
things instead of this.
So we're going to write one
piece of pseudocode that
evaluates these.
So it's just
generalizing this thing.
Something else we
can do is we can
look at how would these things
get computed using memoization?
We can look at how we would
compute shortest path in graphs
with cycles.
So this assumes we have a DAG.
What if we have cycles?
How do we deal with them?
Or we can do another DP problem,
and see how we'd model that.
So, votes?
What do people want to see?
I think we might have time for
two things, out of these four.
So, everyone votes for one.
And we'll start with that.
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: DP problem.
PROFESSOR: OK, so one
vote for DP problem.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: Cyclic.
AUDIENCE: Wait, you
got two or one votes?
PROFESSOR: One vote.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I'll DP.
AUDIENCE: I'll stick
with [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: DP.
PROFESSOR: I think
we're done here.
All right.
So, new DP problem.
So, suppose you have something
like Manhattan's map, which
is basically a lattice.
Fancy math term for a grid.
And suppose it we can
only go forward and down.
So, all the streets are
one way because they
liked how people drive
in San Francisco,
and decided they're going
to do the same craziness.
So, we want to go from s to t.
And there are different
cost on all these edges.
This is an n by m matrix.
And I want to get from s to t
in the shortest possible way.
So, let's model the problem.
And then let's do
recursion formulas
and make it look like a DP
instead of like a graph problem
because-- it might be
too easy of a graph
problem in hindsight.
OK, so what's the graph problem?
AUDIENCE: It's not equivalent.
AUDIENCE: Topological sort.
And then bfs.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Topological sort.
And then, and then that.
Well, let's write
this as, let's say
that each node is so let's say
that the nodes have numbers,
right?
So this is 1,1 and this is 5,4.
And I want to write
this using math, so 2,1.
3,1.
4,1.
5,1.
And then, 1,2.
1,3.
1,4.
OK, so this is the graph.
The shortest path from
here to here is obvious.
By the way, this
is a real problem
for people who don't
see the connection
between dynamic
programming and graphs.
I This problem has tripped
up people on exams before.
So it's not a toy problem.
OK.
AUDIENCE: So, on an
examine, would you
have the option of just using
a straight up graph algorithm--
PROFESSOR: Well, we're going to
ask you to solve this using DP.
So let's try to solve this using
dynamic programming by writing
recursion formulas.
So, what's the shortest
distance to 1,1.
AUDIENCE: 0.
PROFESSOR: OK, then.
If I have a general distance,
if I have some random node here,
dij, how do I compute this?
AUDIENCE: It's a
minimum distance
between the distance
of law plus weights.
AUDIENCE: Or the distance of j.
i minus one.
Yeah.
PROFESSOR: So, i minus 1 j.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
We get it.
Plus the weight of the, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Going from
one to the other.
PROFESSOR: OK, so the weight
from i minus 1 j to ij.
OK.
And?
AUDIENCE: j minus 1i.
For i, j minus 1.
PROFESSOR: ij minus 1.
AUDIENCE: Plus
weight of that ij.
ij minus j1 to ij.
ij [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
So these are the recursions.
Now, how would I write the
full set of code for this?
So what's a valid topological
sort for these guys?
AUDIENCE: 1,1.
2,1.
3,1.
AUDIENCE: Dials.
AUDIENCE: 1,2.
AUDIENCE: The right dials.
PROFESSOR: That's going
to be hard to code.
That's going to be easy to code.
So I'm going to
take your answer.
AUDIENCE: OK.
AUDIENCE: What?
PROFESSOR: I'm not going to take
your answer because your answer
is correct, but
it's hard to code.
AUDIENCE: But isn't that
the same thing [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: She
says, go like this.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
Oh.
PROFESSOR: So, here's how
I'm going to code them.
4i in 1,2n.
4j in 1 to m.
So, I guess, first off, if i
is 1 and j is 1, then d of ij
is 0, right?
This is the base case.
Otherwise, d of ij
equals big bad formula
that we have up there.
OK.
Do we need anything else?
AUDIENCE: DP.
PROFESSOR: This is DP.
We're done.
AUDIENCE: Is it?
PROFESSOR: Almost work.
Yeah, this is--
AUDIENCE: Over [INAUDIBLE]--
AUDIENCE: I thought this
was just programming.
AUDIENCE: --it's a
dictionary, though.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It's programming.
So this is the DP
solution to the program
because, instead of
building the graph,
you're writing the recursion.
And you're writing using
this implicit representation
of the graph.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
PROFESSOR: This is it.
This is DP.
Most people are
really afraid of it.
This is the hardest
thing in the course.
If you get the connection
between graphs and this,
and if you know how to
model graphs, that it.
You're one month
in the term, you're
done with six double six.
You already know
everything to ace the exam.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Aren't graphs
just programming, as well?
PROFESSOR: Ah.
But there, you're building
a graph structure.
Here, we don't need to
build that structure.
Because we see the
connection directly.
Like, this code is
much smaller, right?
It's much easier to look at.
I mean, sorry.
It's faster to read.
But it looks like
black magic if you
don't see the underlying graph.
Yes?
Did you have a question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so.
What exactly is
dynamic programming?
Unless they give at least
one or two examples of,
like, using something that you
had calculated already, or--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --Fibinocci.
So.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So--
AUDIENCE: Ah, so
now you just have
to have a dictionary to
store the minimum cost.
AUDIENCE: That's
what d is, though.
The d of ij.
AUDIENCE: Wait.
PROFESSOR: So.
So I like your question.
And I'm going to address
all the other ones first.
And then I'm going to
spend about five minutes
addressing your question.
What is dynamic
programming, right?
What is the point of this?
Like, what is
dynamic programming?
We're going to
come back to this.
So any questions about this?
AUDIENCE: Wait.
As you're going through--
AUDIENCE: Is there a dictionary?
PROFESSOR: Sure.
This is an array.
Or dictionary.
So, say this is ij.
If it's an array, or
if it's a dictionary,
it would be d of the tuple ij.
So, I can write this
in Python, right?
This is almost Python.
What am I missing?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE],
or it fits inside.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So, I have some boundary
conditions, right?
Because this guy would depend
on this guy, which is inside.
And left to depend on this guy.
Which doesn't exist.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
I wasn't-- OK.
Sure.
PROFESSOR: So, we need
a few more ifs here,
for boundary conditions.
AUDIENCE: I mean, in theory,
though, you could just
run through the
new dfs and create
a topological of the source.
Right?
And just run through that.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
But that's so much
code to write.
Look at this.
This is five lines.
AUDIENCE: Well, yeah.
For this particular
problem, it's five lines.
PROFESSOR: Well, for
dynamic programming,
the solutions are 5 to
10 lines in general.
And the only hard thing
in dynamic programming
is figuring out what is
the state going to be.
So, after you get used to
them, after you solve 10 or 20,
when people come out of
programming contests,
and someone says, my
solution's dynamic programming.
Really?
Wait, you can solve it that way.
And he says, yeah.
This is the state.
And then everything
else is obvious.
Like, it's pretty easy to
figure out everything else.
The hard part is the state.
So, it's enough to
say my solution is
dynamic programming.
This is my state.
You guys are probably
going to have
to say a bit more
than that on the exam.
But this is the hard part.
AUDIENCE: DP.
PROFESSOR: No, you
can't just say DP.
You'll definitely
need at least a state.
OK.
So.
AUDIENCE: You're
also missing a state
for deciding stuff in the
dictionary, though, right?
PROFESSOR: Before deciding
if my key is already
in the dictionary?
Well, so, aside from the
boundary conditions here,
if I compute this here, it
depends on theses two, right?
Are they going to be
in the dictionary?
AUDIENCE: Not yet.
PROFESSOR: Why?
If I'm running
this way, so if I'm
computing all my
values in this order.
So the first line one.
Then line two.
Then line three.
They're already going
to be in the dictionary.
So this is because I'm
doing topological sort.
You don't need
memoization if you're not
using the topological
sort of the graph.
You only need
memoization if you don't.
AUDIENCE: So, why are we doing
boundaries commissions if--
PROFESSOR: Because--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So, I'm doing
a boundary condition
because if I paste this in if I
paste this thing in, then when
I am here, this is going
to refer to this guy.
Which is fine.
But it's also going
to refer to 2,0.
Which doesn't exist.
So the code might be a bit
obfuscated by the boundary
conditions.
But it's 10 lines of code.
It's pretty nice
and straightforward.
OK, now what is
dynamic programming?
I like that question.
PROFESSOR: So, a key
property, I don't
think it was
mentioned in lecture.
Guys, correct me if I'm wrong.
It's called optimal
substructure.
Does that ring a bell?
Probably going to hear
about it next time, so.
Optimal substructure.
So, the point of
optimal substructure
is, suppose I have a
shortest path from s to g.
Right?
so, suppose I have
shortest path from s to g.
And that path is called p.
Now, suppose this
path goes through d.
So, path from s to g is actually
s making a path through d.
And then there's another
path going from d to g.
This path over here, p1.
p1 is guaranteed to be the
shortest path, or a shortest
path, from s to d.
So this is the big solution.
It's optimal because we say it's
the solution to the problem.
This is a part of the solution.
This part of the solution
is optimal for this part
of the problem.
So the part of the problem
is getting from s to d.
The part of the big
optimal solution
is optimal-- so the small
part of the big solution
is optimal with respect
to the small problem.
So p1 has to be a
shortest path from s to d.
Do you guys want to see
a proof by contradiction?
Or do take my word for it?
Does anyone want to?
So, intuitively, the idea is
that if you had the better
path here, say that
path would be s3,
then I could replace
this, sorry. p3.
I could replace this with p3.
And I would have a
better path overall.
And that would
contradict the fact
that this is the best path.
So this part of the path
has to be a shortest path
to get from s to d.
So I've broken up my
problem to get from s to g,
into saying, I want to get
from s to d, from s to e.
Or, from s to f and
then cross one edge.
And then the ways I get from
s to d from s to e, or from s
to f, have to be optimal.
I've already encoded that here.
And nobody asked me,
yo, is this true?
Can I take a longer path here?
And have a better solution?
The answer is no.
In some problems,
the answer is yes.
Those are not
problems that you can
solve with dynamic programming.
if, in your problems,
that's the case,
you probably forgot to account
for some part of the state.
AUDIENCE: What kind
of problems would it
be where that wouldn't be true?
PROFESSOR: Well,
remember the quiz problem
with the gas stations?
If you don't account for the
gas, if you do Dijkstra, then,
well.
Guess what?
Shortest path in
the graph, if that
doesn't account for gas
stops, if you start accounting
for the cost of
refilling, this path
might be longer than a
path that goes like this.
So, it's longer in
terms of road stalls.
But has fewer, or has cheaper,
gas stations on the way.
So then, there's no
optimal substructure.
And that's because you didn't
account for the fuel states.
OK.
Probably not the best example.
Sorry for bringing
up painful memories.
But the point is,
usually when you
have this with our problems, you
didn't account for the state.
All the problems that are
solved with dynamic programming
have this thing called
optimal substructure.
And this is sort
of how it works.
OK.
I have no idea how much time I
have because my phone crashed.
So can anyone help me?
Five minutes.
10 minutes.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Seven minutes.
PROFESSOR: OK.
What else do you
guys want to see?
AUDIENCE: Cycles.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
Is everyone happy with cycles?
OK.
Almost everyone, so
that's good enough.
OK.
Let's do cycles.
We have seven minutes.
So, suppose I have this graph.
Source going a going
to be going to c.
And then the costs
are 1 minus 1.
1.
Can I solve it
using that method?
Probably not.
Let's try to write
the recursions
to see what we get
for the formulas.
So, dsa is--
AUDIENCE: 1.
PROFESSOR: --minimum.
Yeah, it's 1.
But it's the minimum
of dss plus weight sa.
ds-- well, almost.
Actually, it's not 1.
Likely.
You're confusing me again.
There's one more edges that
they have to account for.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
PROFESSOR: dsc plus weight.
I'm going to fail today.
I'm tired.
AUDIENCE: ca.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So we accounted for both
edges coming in now.
dsb is minimum of
dsa plus weight ab.
dsc is minimum of
dsb plus weight bc.
Right?
And dss is 0 because we
promised that's how we start.
OK.
Now what if I try
evaluate these?
Is there a sane order in
which I can evaluate them?
Nope.
Let's see why.
If I try to evaluate
sa, this depends on sc.
AUDIENCE: Which
we don't have yet.
PROFESSOR: sc is here.
sc depends on sb.
sb is here.
And it depends on sa.
Which was.
So we have this infinite
recursion, right?
They all depend on each other.
There's a loop here.
There's a negative cycle.
Can't use this algorithm.
That's a shame.
What can we do instead?
PROFESSOR: Show a negative node.
A negative weight.
half.
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Can we just get rid
of the negative weight half?
PROFESSOR: No.
That's the best edge.
That's probably going to be
part of the solution, right?
AUDIENCE: Can we add
1 to all the edges?
PROFESSOR: That's still
going to have a cycle.
I still won't be
able to run this.
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Bellman-Ford.
PROFESSOR: Bellman-ford.
AUDIENCE: That's not dynamic.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Well, one way to do it
is Bellman-Ford, right?
Another way, which we
went through last time,
is to break the cycle.
And the way we break
the cycle is we
add the path length
into the equation.
So, I'm going to
look at the distance
from a source to some
node, so the distance
from a source to some node, as
the distance from the source
to some other node
plus the edge weight.
This is what I
had before, right?
Nothing new here.
So dsv is the minimum
over all the edges of dsu
plus weight uv, Right?
Minimum over all uv.
That's our edges.
Right?
This is the old stuff.
Now, we're going to
say this instead.
The distance from s to v,
using a path of length k,
is the minimum over all the
edges of the distance from s
to u, using a path
of what length?
If this path is length k.
So k edges.
How many edges do I have here?
AUDIENCE: k equals 1.
PROFESSOR: So this is
distance su using k minus 1
plus the weight of uv.
AUDIENCE: So what's the
difference between the two?
PROFESSOR: So, this
will always decrease.
So I guarantee that they will
not have an infinite recursion.
This is the magic
that makes it work.
Now, an equivalent way
of looking at this,
is building a graph.
That's what we've
been doing so far.
So let's build an
equivalent graph to this.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It's going to
get to 0 eventually, right?
So when k is 0, the distance
from the source to itself is 0.
But the distance from the source
to any other nodes is infinity.
Because from the
source, we can't
get to anywhere else in 0 edges.
We can't teleport.
So let's build a graph to
get the intuition for this.
This looks mathy.
This looks too mathy.
So, at the first layer,
you only have the source.
You can only get from
the source to itself
by not crossing any edges.
At level one, you potentially
have all the nodes.
If the source is
connected to everything,
you might have all the nodes.
So, s1, a1, b1, c1.
Where can you get
from the source?
AUDIENCE: To a.
PROFESSOR: To a.
What's the cost of the edge?
AUDIENCE: 1.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Now, let's build a second layer.
s2, a2, b2, c2.
So someone tell me the edges.
So, assuming I can get
to this node using one
edge, how can I get to this
other node using two edges?
AUDIENCE: A to b.
PROFESSOR: OK. a to b.
a1 to b2.
AUDIENCE: 2.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Cost?
AUDIENCE: 1 [INAUDIBLE].
A1 to c--
AUDIENCE: That's negative 1.
PROFESSOR: a1 to b2.
Thank you.
OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Are we
doing anything else?
PROFESSOR: I think so.
So, if I'm at b using one edge,
I can get to c using two edges.
Cost?
AUDIENCE: 1.
PROFESSOR: OK.
If I'm at c using one edge--
AUDIENCE: a.
PROFESSOR: --using two edges.
Cost?
AUDIENCE: 1.
PROFESSOR: OK.
And if I'm at s using one edge?
AUDIENCE: a.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Can you?
AUDIENCE: There's now edge.
PROFESSOR: There's no edge.
AUDIENCE: I thought it was
just like an assumed edge.
PROFESSOR: Nope.
Nope.
Not an edge.
As to a, cost?
AUDIENCE: 1.
PROFESSOR: 1.
OK.
Let's build a third level.
s3, a3, b3, c3.
Someone dictate
the edges please.
AUDIENCE: S2 to a3.
With 1.
I mean, it's going
to be the exact same.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
a2 to b3 minus 1.
b2 to c3 1.
And c2 to a3 1.
So these are exactly
the same edges, right?
Because they're the
original edges in the graph.
Every edge in the graph
can connect to levels here.
So, all edges.
All edges.
All edges from s.
How many layers do I need?
AUDIENCE: e.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Pretty close.
Let's try something smaller.
AUDIENCE: a.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
That makes no sense.
PROFESSOR: So, what's the
longest path in a graph?
Graph of v vertices.
What is the longest path?
AUDIENCE: The
number [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: The
longest shortest path.
AUDIENCE: v minus 1.
PROFESSOR: v minus 1.
That's how Bellman-Ford
has v minus 1 runs, right?
AUDIENCE: Oh.
PROFESSOR: So, a shortest
path can't have a cycle.
If it has a cycle, then it
means it's an infinite cycle.
So there's no solution.
Shortest paths have
no cycles therefore,
even if they go through
the entire graph,
they're going to
have v minus 1 edges.
So I'm going to have
v minus 1 layers.
Here, I drew three
layers, so I'm done.
That's why I stopped at three.
So let's see how many nodes
and how many edges we're
going to have if we do
this transformation.
v prime is-- so, how many times
am I going to copy the graph?
AUDIENCE: Two or thee times.
AUDIENCE: Three times.
PROFESSOR: OK.
And in general terms?
AUDIENCE: v minus 1.
AUDIENCE: v minus 1 times.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So I'm going to copy the
graph v minus 1 times.
And then I'm going to add
that one source, right?
Doesn't really matter because
it's order of b squared.
How many edges?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Order of v times e.
We can do the math
that's whatever.
Let's say it's
something like this.
So the running time-- this
graph is acyclic, right?
All the nodes are going forward.
The new graph that I have here.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: So, I can
use the DAG algorithm.
So the running time, if
I use the DAG algorithm,
is v prime plus e prime.
Which is?
AUDIENCE: v.
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Or is it ve?
PROFESSOR: So, it's v
squared plus ve, which is ve,
for most purposes.
And this is?
AUDIENCE: Bellman-Ford.
PROFESSOR: Bellman-Ford.
So this is Bellman-Ford.
This is what Bellman-Ford does.
Except when you're
coding it up, it
relaxes the edges
in a different way.
But this is the intuition
behind Bellman-Ford.
And this is an easy way to
see why Bellman-Ford works.
AUDIENCE: So,
practically, we really
wouldn't want to do
dynamic programming.
We just want to run
Bellman-Ford because that's
less code, right?
PROFESSOR: So, this is
the dynamic programming
view of Bellman-Ford.
Write Bellman-Ford.
There's a reason why we taught
you to write it that way.
It's going to be shorter.
This just gives
you more intuition.
And it shows you how
the DAG algorithm
relates to Bellman-Ford.
And this is how we handle
cycles, which are removed.
So, that means I have fulfilled
my promise of covering
two of the issues that
I had on the board.
Yes.
So any questions about this?
So, we didn't do the
pseudocode for the shortest
path using DAGs.
The code that we gave
you in the code handout
matches the pseudocode
that you'd write.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So, if all edges
were negative 1 here,
except for the top edge,
looking at this graph over here,
how would the search go through,
such that it would find,
lik,e negative two weight half?
PROFESSOR: So these
edges are minus 1?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Well, do you have
a solution in this case?
AUDIENCE: It's no.
PROFESSOR: No.
But you could have this, right?
And expect the
whole thing to work.
AUDIENCE: No, that's still
not, that's not making sense.
PROFESSOR: Is it?
AUDIENCE: It's negative 1 cycle.
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah.
That's unfortunate.
OK.
Never mind.
Do like this?
OK.
AUDIENCE: So, also,
looking at the graph,
there's only one natural
path that you can take.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
So, if I go from s to
c, like this, sabc,
this is going to
be s0, a1, b2, c3.
So, all the paths go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So, what if I
wanted to find the shortest
path to s to b?
Like, in terms of actually
writing an algorithm,
would it be s0, a1, b2, or s1?
a2, b3.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So, if you actually want
to read the shortest path,
then the shortest path could
have length 1, length 2,
or length 3, right?
I don't know.
So I would have to
look at all these.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
OK.
So you just run it from
s0 to any b, basically.
PROFESSOR: So, the algorithm
that we have there computes
the path from one source
to everything else.
So I run it.
It runs.
Computes all the shortest paths.
And then I have to
read these ones.
And get the smallest one.
That's a question.
Thank you.
Yeah, that is a detail
that I left out.
Thank you.
So, no more cycles.
OK.
Any other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I'm still, like, on
the initial problem and stuff.
A bit of a disconnect.
When you were underlining
stuff, like the sa,
it seemed to me that,
like, in that case,
when you're going
forward, you're never
going to stop because
you're doing recursion.
So you never have a
beginning point, almost.
Effectively, if you, like--
PROFESSOR: So, do you mean here?
AUDIENCE: Well, yeah.
PROFESSOR: So, in that case,
this is the beginning point.
AUDIENCE: Right.
PROFESSOR: If I go through the
nodes in the topological sort
order, then all I need
is one beginning point.
Because everything else
will refer back to that.
There has to be a
topological sort order.
And the first node in
that order is my source.
And, if we have cycles, then the
beginning conditions are here.
So that's why I'm only
drawing this vertex.
Because these other
vertices wouldn't be useful.
OK.
So then, that being said, don't
forget your quizzes and happy
Thanksgiving.